today I'm going to talk about
measurements of human brain structure
conducted with MRI and how we're using
some pretty simple principles from
statistical learning to understand these
measurements interpret these
measurements this is all done in the
context of a open-source software
project called die PI but stands for
diffusion imaging in Python I'll explain
what diffusion imaging is in in just a
second first of all just to mention you
can see these slides over here you can
follow along if you want or review these
these slides afterwards just to give a
little bit of context I'm part of a an
Institute at the University of
Washington called the Science Institute
we're a group of researchers from a
variety of fields this this institute is
very interdisciplinary and together
we're trying to tackle data intensive
research across a variety of fields and
that includes integrating together
understanding from fields like
statistical learning into neuroscience
and the application of these ideas in
software that scientists that other
scientists can also use so this this
project Falls pretty squarely under
these ideas but it's also the
continuation of research that I did as a
postdoc in at Stanford University and
Brian Juan Del's group there in the
Department of Psychology so I should
give credit there as well and now I'll
mention my collaborators at the end so
the research that we do is based on an
understanding that's actually pretty old
these gentlemen in the center of this
image are all neurologists and the that
in the 19th century started noticing
patterns that we're occurred in patients
where damage to connections between
different parts of the brain were
associated with very particular kinds of
behavioral deficits so connections
between say the temporal lobe over here
on this side of the brain so this is a
human brain this
the front of the brain this is the back
of the brain we called this part of here
the temporal lobe and one of the one of
these findings was very important
finding that a connection between the
temporal lobe and what we call the
frontal lobe over here in the front
leads the particular damage for example
in the ability to speak okay and there
there are insight from that was that our
normal behavior is supported by the
existence of brain connections they
understood then that the brain is a big
network that is connected through
connections between cells that exist on
the surface of our brain called the
cortex through long-range projections
that connect those those different parts
this was even before people knew exactly
what are those those the substrates what
are the nerve cells that that connect
between them but they could already at
that point know that normal behaviors is
is supported by connectivity now this is
again a human brain in this case parts
of the temporal lobe and parts of the
back of the brain the occipital lobe
have been dissected out this is a view
from the bottom of a brain so we're
looking again this is the front of the
brain this is the back of the brain and
we're looking at the brain from the
bottom up here the this part has been
dissected away and what you can see is
that the white matter is organized in
very large bundles now each one of these
bundles is not a single cell that is
connected it's rather thousands many
many thousands of cells that are
connected through what we call white
matter fascicles so we call this white
matter because the internal part of the
brain contains a lot of fat and is
brighter and then the outer part of the
brain that we refer to as gray matter
and so these bundles are the bundles
that support this normal functioning of
the brain but we also understand now
that they're not just passive cables
these brain connections change with
development they explain individual
differences that in behavior so if
our differences in the size of these of
these cables in the extent to which they
change with development that can have an
effect on on behavior they did that with
learning so they can change even within
a particular individual over a long time
in development but also quickly with
learning of new information and this has
of course clinical significance because
damage to these parts of the brain has
has an effect as I mentioned before on
our behavior the only way that we
currently have to probe these
connections in a non-invasive manner in
humans is magnetic resonance imaging
romantic resonance imaging allows us to
measure many different kinds of aspects
of brain function we can measure neural
activity with a method called functional
MRI or fMRI we can measure the anatomy
of the brain the gross anatomy of the
brain through methods of structural MRI
and there are many other measurements
that can be done with with MRI and
specifically today I will be talking
about a measurement called diffusion MRI
which allows us to probe the brain
connections in vivo in in a living human
brain at millimeter resolution diffusion
MRI relies on the fact that water exists
within all these different parts of the
brain and if we zoom in on one of these
things so now we're zooming in in a
microscope this is a microscopic image
on one of these bundles they're made out
of a lot of these tubes and each one of
these tubes really is a single cell the
part of the cell that connects different
parts of the brain the part of the cell
that that projects forward into other
parts is called the axon and these are
axons of individual cells wrapped
together in one of these big fascicles
and those there's water everywhere and
those in those parts now here's sort of
a toy example of what this might look
like if we had a cell that's completely
around water would be free to diffuse
within the cell in all directions
equally and we'd call that isotropic
diffusion but if you think about one of
these tubes
water is now free to diffuse along the
length of this tube along the length of
the axon more than across the boundaries
of the axon and this kind of diffusion
is anisotropic
and we can ever measure this anisotropy
so here it is in in the tubes themselves
right there's more more diffusion along
the length than across the boundaries
and the way that we can measure this
anisotropy is by the application of
begin etic field gradients across the
the brain as we're measuring the making
the MRI measurement that's the main
principle diffusion MRI so here in this
panel what you see is the rotation of
the gradients around this here is a
slice through the brain in an MRI image
it's the entire brain so here's the
front of the brain here is the back of
the brain it's called the horizontal
slices a horizontal slice through the
brain this here is a sagittal slice so
it's a slight straight through here what
we're looking here is in the middle of
the brain so here again is the front
here's the back here is the top of the
brain and the bottom of the brain this
here is an axial slice so it's a slice
through like this and this slice this is
the left side and the right side of the
brain the top and the bottom
all of these slices are through the
middle of the brain what you can see is
that as we rotate the gradients around
the measurement is sensitive to
diffusion in different directions so it
becomes brighter when diffusion is
restricted in the direction along which
the gradient is oriented so if you see
when this is oriented like this it'll
come back again you'll see that it
becomes bright in this region here and
maybe when the the gradients are
oriented like that they'll be restricted
around these parts of the brain and this
restriction indicates to us or this this
brightening of the images indicates that
in which directions there is restriction
of diffusion of water and that indicates
to us where diffusion is anisotropic but
also in which direction this anisotropy
exists let's look at this in a little
bit more detail so here is a measurement
from a single location in the brain we
divide up the brain into these boxes of
roughly 1 millimeter on each side and
those are called voxel or volumetric
Souls this is a measurement from a
single voxel and each one of these
spheres represents a single gradient
direction so what you can see here is
that and the distance from the distance
from the center of this this cloud is
the distance the estimated distance of
diffusion along that direction so when
the gradient was applied in this
direction for example that you see right
here
water diffused pretty far but if it was
in this direction water she was pretty
closely so in this case diffusion is
Anna's anisotropic it's a nice tropical
Ong a particular axis of diffusion now
we can take and build a simple model and
that's the the basic operation we first
do with this kind of data so to build a
simple model of this diffusion what are
the classic models that's been used in
this field it's called the diffusion
tensor model the diffusion tensor model
approximates this diffusion as a three
dimensional Gaussian distribution so
there's how much variance is there occur
along each one of the axes of space and
how much covariance is there between the
different axes and when you you build
such a model you can say here is the
smooth approximation of this data by the
model you can see here this is server in
the look to coal soy oil sheiks oh
there's more diffusion along this axis
then say along this axis so this is the
first step in analyzing the data is
modeling diffusion in every single
location in which the measurement was
conducted this is very useful because we
can estimate certain physical properties
of the tissue from this for example here
is again a horizontal slice through
roughly the middle of the brain you'll
see that there is we've been able to
extract out of the model a an estimate
of mean diffusivity so wherever there's
very low diffusivity water can only move
very close to the center that means that
the tissue might be much denser there
see that there are these areas of very
high diffusivity these are actually
holes inside the brain cavities inside
the brain called ventricles that contain
only water so tissue is very low density
there is almost purely water and
diffusivity is very very high in those
regions another kind of statistic we can
derive from this kind of model is the
fractional and I softer
so this refers to how pointy this
ellipsoid shape is right so if it's very
very pointy we say that anisotropy is
very very high and you can see that
anisotropy again along in different
regions of the brain and anisotropy
varies quite a bit here where we are in
the core of the white matter where there
really is a dense dense pack of these
white matter fibers and I saw trapeze
very very high and that's because water
is really restricted in one direction or
rather free to diffuse along really one
direction the direction of the fibers in
those locations you can see that this
forms an interesting pattern in the
brain finally we can derive from this
kind of model this diffusion tensor
model we can drive the principal
diffusion direction again this is
corresponds roughly to the axis of this
of the the highest of the highest
diffusion the highest variance of
diffusion and we can use these
directions in order to now estimate
connectivity so that's the next step
that I will show is how we estimate from
the diffusion two tracts that connect
different parts of the brain again I
show you a horizontal slice through the
brain and I'm going to zoom in on this
little box when we zoom on this box now
you can see the voxels the edges of the
voxels these little one by one by one or
in this case two by two by two
millimeter box boxes inside the brain we
estimate one of these diffusion tensor
ellipsoids and every one of these boxes
and now we can treat the principal
diffusion direction of every one of
these boxes as a vector and propagate a
stream line through this vector field
like this to say that there may be a
connection that goes through this part
of the brain in this manner
it's just connecting the dots from one
voxel to the next and when we do this
many many times here through this
frontal portion of the single
individuals brain we might get an
estimate of sort of larger scale
anatomical structure anatomical
connectivity in this case these fibers
all go through this yellow region of
interest that we call the corpus
callosum this is
big bundle of fibers that connects the
two hemispheres the two sides of the
brain so this gives us a model of the
anatomical connectivity across the
hemispheres in this part of the brain
now all the steps that I've shown you so
far we do using type I and I'll just
sort of talk a little bit about about
type I and then I'll present the
problems that we try to solve using
statistical learning and talk about that
a little bit right pi is part of the
larger community that we call nihai
nihai stands for neuroimaging python
it's a very widespread community
worldwide of people who are
practitioners doing research in
neuroimaging using Python and using a
variety of different kinds of
measurements and different kinds of
software a lot of projects around around
this community die by itself diffusion
imaging in Python was started by alfihri
Euler felides
was now postdoc in in Canada there are
contributors from at least six different
countries and many many different labs
this graph shows the growth in
contributions in this project it's kind
of a nice graph to look at there was a
some kind of an explosion 2013 and
growing steadily ever since the library
contains implementations of many
algorithms used both for this tracking
that I just showed you and free
construction the modeling of individual
voxels
it also contains other modules for other
kinds of computational neural Anatomy
tasks so we're using die pipe to do
these things this is all looking pretty
great so far you might ask yourself so
what is the problem well Julian MRI has
a big challenge in validating its
results for example if you use two
different algorithms you might get quite
different views of the brain these are
two different algorithms that both apply
to the same data and when you use those
different algorithms you can get either
a very narrow view so this is this is
the same Kinect
that I talked about at the beginning
between the temporal lobe and the
frontal lobe it's called the arcuate
fasciculus it it plays an important role
in in producing speech and understanding
speech and depending on the algorithm
that you use in this particular
individuals brain you might think that
the arcuate fasciculus is this narrow
small bit that's fairly focused in its
ends or that it's this sprawling big
thing and the pattern of connectivity at
the level of the cortex is also quite
different it's either very focused and
narrow or really connecting very large
swaths of cortex so how do we know which
which of these models is a better model
of the brain jan saw that we've we've
taken a statistical learning approach
something we also call in vivo
validation in vivo in contrast to ex
vivo in ex vivo would be the anatomical
dissection that I showed you before some
have said you can take this brain and
you can open it up right you can dissect
this brain and look and see which one of
these solutions is better but we don't
actually want to do that because it
would be very hard to find volunteers
willing to go through that and be the
dissections themselves in anatomical
methods also have their own confounds
they're not representing necessarily a
ground truth they're just representing
another kind of method method of
measurement that has its own errors is
that we want to validate our models
against the measurement itself do that
you use a cross-validation approach in
cross-validation we make one measurement
so here is again 150 different
directions of gradients it's the same as
the the measurements they're showed you
before is the cloud now I just show them
as a series we can make a second
measurement in the same location in the
brain in the same individual and we can
compare these measurements to each other
this gives us the test-retest
reliability of the measurement itself
for comparison we can fit a model to one
of these one of these signals and then
try to predict from the model the second
measurement and that's called
cross-validation this allows us to
compare model performance in
cross-validation
to test retest reliability we can
distill down the the differences into
one number that we call the relative
root mean squared error this is the root
mean squared error root mean squared
error of model prediction in
cross-validation relative to the root
mean squared error of test retest
reliability and if the relative root
mean squared error is smaller than one
that means that mall predictions are
better than the snr of the measurement
itself and we consider that a good model
if we manage to reduce the the noise
further than making another measurement
we consider modeling a worthwhile
exercise relative to for example
measuring another measurement in that
pie we've implemented a very simple
cross validation API it is the the user
enters a gradient table that tells us
which gradients were measured which
directions of diffusion were probed and
then some reconstruction model is is
generated call that uh using this this
measurement so at this point there's no
data yet once we input into this model
use the model fit method on this data
that gives us a fit object or
reconstruction fit object and this
reconstruction fit object then has a
prediction method that can be applied
again to either the measurement gradient
table the measurement scheme that we
used initially or to another measurement
extrapolating out of this measurement to
another measurement that we some unseen
data for those of you used scikit-learn
this will look pretty familiar it's a
similar very similar API but notice that
it embodies knowledge about radiant
tables about these particular data so in
embodies the the scientific knowledge as
well as as an API of sort of general
statistical learning for example for the
tensor model that I showed you before
the simple SOI proximation of the data
this is what the code would look like
user would instantiate a model using the
GTI tensor model object then the model
would be fake to one data a prediction
would generate it again on the gradient
table and then this prediction would be
compared to a second measurement for
cross-validation we can then compute the
relative root mean square by comparing
the model root mean squared error to
data to data reliability again test
retest reliability and that gives us the
relative root mean squared error and
this is what it looks like for the
tensor model in a single individual you
can see that the relative root mean
squared error is green in a lot of the
brain so actually in most kinds of
measurements that we make we find that
the tensor model is better than
test-retest reliability in about 97% of
the brain I'm actually focused here on
the one part of the brain where a
customer tests reliabilities is actually
worse in the tensor model that where the
the tensor model is errors are larger
than test-retest reliability and we
actually know why just why the tensor
model doesn't perform very well here
that's because this part of the brain
contains the crossings of several
different large bundles of fibers the
corpus callosum that I showed you before
the crosses between the hemispheres but
also the corticospinal tract that
connects the cortex with our spine and
allows us to control muscular motion and
and other fibers that pass through going
front to back and that's the reason the
DTI or diffusion tensor imaging this
tensor model doesn't perform very well
there it can't really handle crossings
and fibers but other models the to take
into account this notion of crossings of
fibers can actually perform quite well
there and and we have models that
account for the data are better than
test-retest reliability and 99.9% of the
voxels in the brain so we actually have
quite good models for this kind of data
now you might ask what if you've only
measured ones most practitioners only
measure months well we've developed a
k-fold cross-validation API that allows
people to provide us with their model
provide us with their data and then what
kind of split they want to do on the
data and they can and then you
this API part of the magic that makes
this API able to work across different
models is the fact that we've
implemented similar fit and prediction
API across the different models now this
notion that we can compare the model
that we have of the brain to the data
itself can generalize also to a broader
larger scale so as I showed you before
different algorithms produce different
images not only of the signal at the
local scale but also of connectivity at
a larger scale to be able to evaluate
these fascicle models franco stilly and
and others in Brian Wendell's lab when I
was a postdoc there we developed this
method called linear fascicle evaluation
it is that you build the forward model
from the tracks to the measured signal
here's the idea let's say that we've
estimated one stream line over here and
then another stream line over here and
want to validate these stream lines
against the data we can take these
stream lines and create a forward model
that tells us what the predicted signal
would be from this fiber by itself and
then another column is in in this in
this prediction would correspond to the
predictions of this other fascicle this
other track as you can see in some
places there's no prediction at all
because those are parts of the brain
where this stream line doesn't pass
through so there are some places in
which there are predictions from both
fascicles and parts of the brain in
which there are only predictions from
one of the fast goals we can then do
this for many many fascicles we get
millions of fascicles at a time for
these estimation algorithms and compare
it to the data as it was measured in the
scanner this forms a large linear model
here X is the matrix of all the
predictions from all the stream lines
beta is a set of estimated weights that
we will estimate through a procedure of
model fitting and Y is the data that was
actually measured in all these locations
in the brain
and we solve that for beta larger than
zero so for non-negative non negative
weights on each one of these fibers a
part of the challenge of doing this is
that the shape of this matrix ends up
being rather large as I said there are
millions of these fibers that go through
millimeter scale measurements across
entire brains it becomes a pretty large
problem here's what the code that looks
like in die pine has a similar very
similar structure to the structure that
I showed you before for the models of
individual voxels so we create a fiber
model so this is the life module linear
fascicle evaluation module we tell it
about the measurement that we did and
then we fit this measurement using both
the data that was actually measured and
the tracks that were estimated from this
data using one of these tracking
algorithms and then we can again so for
the fitting in the fitting procedure
here what happens is the fitting of this
large linear model the summation of
these non non negative weights that I
described before
once the prediction is done or once the
fitting is done we can actually go in
and try to predict what would the signal
look like and confront that with the
data itself estimating the error of
these tracks relative to the signal this
also gives us another kind of aspect on
this which is that it allows us to
select which of the tracks actually fits
the data those will be the tracks that
received a weight larger than 0 so in
actually in practice what happens is
that many of these weights go to go to 0
and we can reduce the amount of data
reduce the amount of tracks that we get
a lot by looking only at the tracks that
have weights larger than 0 just
summarize I've told you today how we
measure brain connectivity using
diffusion MRI I told you a little bit
about the Dipak project that we're using
in order to analyze these data
particularly focused on the validation
problem and this notion of in vivo
validation how we're using statistical
learning in order to validate the models
that we estimate
for connectivity of different parts of
the brain I'd like to just mention my
collaborators on on this work on the dye
pie side of theros who started the
project stefan von der vault is now
being mentioned for the second time
today if you noticed in josh blooms
slides earlier who was involved in this
work and Barbara and Rebecca and there
were many other collaborators on dye pie
but I'm mentioning these people in
particular who involved in this
statistical validation effort and then
at Stanford during my postdoc I worked
in Brian one Del's lab Franco castelia
was the the lead author on this linear
fascicle evaluation approach and then
these are all my contact details if
you'd like to talk about this you can
get in touch with me and I'd be happy to
take questions about polls